we're going to begin with the derek
shovin trial it has brought back a flood
of emotions for those watching all
around the country
and all around the world but arguably
nowhere more so than in minneapolis
itself the city where george floyd was
killed last may more than 10 months
after his death
we spoke to people in minneapolis to
find out how the trial is affecting them
as they watch it all unfold my name is
nakima levy armstrong
i'm a minneapolis-based civil rights
attorney and activist
i'm rt rabback ceo of the minneapolis
foundation and former mayor of
minneapolis
i am p.j hill i'm a community member
i'm a member of the church on 38th in
chicago i am the vice president of the
naacp
minneapolis chapter my name is sherry
albers
i live eight blocks from where george
floyd was killed
it's a daily gut punch i think for me
and
a lot of others in this community to see
the word minneapolis connected to
such a hideous crime it showed the video
again that was my first time watching it
in a long time i mean since it actually
happened
and man literally tears got in my eyes
and then literally
anger just at what we seem sometimes i
feel
traumatized from watching the witnesses
in particular
hearing the desperation in their voices
on those bystander videos is he
breathing right now
it's really sad and disheartening to
think about what they went through
and the burdens that they still carry
with them i didn't intend to watch the
trial
um i thought i had seen enough and i
turned it on on monday morning and i
couldn't stop
watching it it was too traumatic but i
felt
i needed to bear witness to what had
happened
our community is hurt we're healing and
now the trial is like ripping the
band-aid off
all over again
the trial is very traumatizing for many
of us in the african-american community
walking through every piece of this is
absolutely
excruciating but it's exactly what we
need to do
because the the the notion of
learning what is wrong of relearning
what was wrong as well
is playing out right now in front of our
eyes this was
the impetus for change i'm hopeful
that there's change i had good change
something inside all of us broke
you know what's going to happen this
this trial could really change the
landscape of things not only from
minneapolis
but the nation